bonjour antoine alors quelle est la
situation actuelle en russie et bien
comme dans le reste de l'europe la
russie fait face à une recrudescence du
nombre de cas de qovu 19 et en réponse
l'autorité sanitaire russe a de nouveau
rendu obligatoire le port du masque dans
les endroits fermés tels que les
transports en commun les taxis parkings
et autres ascenseurs autre mesure alors
ce n'est pas encore le couvre-feu mais
on s'en rapproche
l'interdiction d'événements publics et
la fermeture des bars et restaurants
entre 23 heures et 6 heures du matin il
s'agit d'une directive pour l'ensemble
du pays certes mais dont l'application
sera du ressort des autorités régionales
bref pour le kremlin la situation est
préoccupante mais pas dramatique écouter
le président a dit que les chiffres
officiels sont quand même des valeurs
moyennes bien évidemment face à ces
poussées épidémiques sans précédent il y
à des situations de crise ici et là il
nous faut les étudier très soigneusement
pour que ces problèmes ne s'aggrave pas
et ne deviennent pas systémique c'est
autre chose
mais sur le plan conceptuel le système
de santé bien sûr beaucoup plus près à
ce stress épidémiologique auxquels il
fait face dans le monde entier on viens
de l'entendre les autorités estiment
avoir le contrôle de la situation
elles font confiance au système de santé
et attendent également beaucoup du
vaccin spoutnik v qui va commencer à
être dispensés à la population ces
prochaines semaines mais surtout moscou
cherche à tout prix à éviter d'imposer à
nouveau des mesures de confinement qui
aurait un impact désastreux sur
l'économie
merci en pointe pour toutes ces
précisions